in separate new year speeches the
leaders of both Russia and Ukraine vowed
to push for victory over each other
fresh blasts were heard in Ukraine's
Capital Kiev and around the country
Russia bombed cities across Ukraine on
Saturday sending a barrage of over 20
cruise missiles Keith mayor of Italy
Klitschko said at least one person was
killed and a Japanese journalist is
among those injured
and for more on this let's bring in our
correspondent in kiv Emmanuel
Emmanuel 2023 in Ukraine as we just
heard off to a very rough start tell us
the latest about the attacks if you
would
hi Nick and happy New Year first yes a
very hard time here in Kiev we've just
been through three days of constant
airstrike threat and as tracks we had
three nights with missile attacks just
last night there was a very very long
threat which lasted four hours during
which 32 Shahid Iranian drones were shot
down over Kiev yesterday midsize a
struck the capital the Ukrainian Capital
there's a hotel which had been hit and
you mentioned it earlier 22 people were
injured someone died so a very very
rough times to be to end the 2022 for
ukrainians and to begin this New Year
2023
and you spent as did many residents of
the capital a good part of the night in
a bomb shelter with key residents who
knew
of course the rest of the world was
ringing in the new year with joy what's
the morale uh among people there
well uh it was pretty strange especially
those
those kids we spent we people here
living in Kiev we spent so much time
Underground just you know hearing
explosions outside sometimes here in the
city center with walls shattering with
Windows uh shattering as well so it's
very scary and we've had in the report
this woman saying she was hoping for a
miracle you know yesterday people in the
morning it was a beautiful morning a
Sunday morning the last day of a very
hard year people were looking forward to
celebrate instead they were stuck
underground they were hearing explosions
above above above them they live in fear
of course they're resilient but there's
fear there as well and there's a sense
of dread because they don't know when
this all will end
and if the president President Vladimir
zielinski made as presidents do a New
Year's address tell us more about that
and how it was received if you don't
mind
well this address was very particular I
was talking about it earlier with uh
with Ukrainian friends who told me all
the people that I know he watched this
address they wouldn't necessarily do
that every year but this year is so
particular and this year really also saw
Vladimir zielinsky gaining you know the
trust of every Ukrainian many people
here didn't vote for him as a president
but then he really revealed himself as
the country's leader on February 24th
and ukrainians at the moment really
rally around him and his speech was very
much centered on ukrainians themselves
on on their you know their solidarity on
the fact that they had to stand together
to face the terrible this terrible war
that is unfolded unfolding against them
so this address was very much followed
very much appreciated as well and very
emotional
okay as well one can well imagine dwc
manual has reporting force from the
Ukrainian Capital thanks so much